you know I want to compliment you your
very fine performer you really are thank
you and I have shared the stage many
times I've always been very impressed
with your skills
likewise yeah well thank you that's all
I wanted you had everybody know but you
you're very you have a very a very wide
range of different kinds of talents you
do like you do very good accents very
and you have a good ear but since you're
a musician I think you're very good at
picking up subtle differences in
different kinds of accents some people
just do very broad ones yours are a very
subtle like you do different accents for
the different states in the United
States which i think is fascinating yeah
I try to you know I stick to the ones
that I I'm interested in and that I know
right so I just like I do this thing
sometimes we're all like I'll have a map
onstage and I'll just sort of point to a
city and start doing that accent
sometimes I ask the audience like okay
where are you from and I just go from
there right so can you give us some can
you can you tell me some accents right
sure let's see if I were to start in
Chicago Chicago is kind of flat here and
right Chicago but it's a little faster
but then the Wisconsin kind of flattens
out a little more here yeah that's cool
yeah yeah more flat yeah yeah she Neely
sound more Chicago than Chicago and then
Minneapolis starts to kind of go in here
a little bit almost almost Canadian yeah
and oh yeah and then that Dumont iana it
starts to there's a sort of they put a
why in some of the vowels you're Monte
Anna and then going and then going west
and then Seattle is a very
presentational accent Seattle is very
it's like they're presenting you yes go
there all the time my wife is from
Seattle and we go there all the time to
see her parents and yes you're exactly
right they always act like they're
showing you a new car they bought yeah
yeah it's like a little every words like
a little gift yeah yeah and then going
down through Portland Portland kind of a
sort of well you would know Portland
yeah yeah like a very angry NPR house oh
yeah yeah and then San Francisco is very
clipped San Francisco's got a very
factual this is a fact and then as you
come down to this area Southern
California is a little bit right now
in San Diego there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]